welcome to bananamores i can't even
contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
hi thank you so much for having me my
name is sam morrison i live in new york
city but
i don't like it because it's gross only
city where like water falls on you
and you're like oh god oh no that could
be
anything oh oh good
it's just tears that's i gave money to a
homeless man
um and my friend those you know real new
yorkers don't give money to the homeless
i was like real new yorkers are homeless
you think you're more new yorker than j
train bagel tony
his best friend's a bagel like you can't
win
i was walking down the street with my
boyfriend one time this guy told us to
go back to where we come from
which is weird because we're white and
gay this guy
thinks there's a country
like i guess where gay people come
from which means he knows about
canada that's our secret okay
you and i i think my favorite part
about being gay is that um i don't have
to follow the rules
like there's a lot of rules you gotta
follow when you're a man when you're
like a straight man you got to be manly
you got not me i'm free i can do this
look at me i can wear i can wear
earrings
men can't wear earrings but they can
wear watches because time is straight
but sound is gay
it's like who made these rules you can't
wear shorts that are too short those are
gay long shorts
those are cool but capris are gay pants
are straight pants suits are lesbian
and theater is gay but if you're in your
underwear it's wrestling
had time to memorize these 300 years ago
they were opposite
like men were heels and wigs and makeup
heels wigs
makeup i'm sorry if george washington
were here today ross matthews would take
one look at him like we need that queen
on drag race
legs for days beat to the gods
sure she doesn't have teeth but honey
she has charisma
they'd have a whole season of course i'd
be called founding daddies
guys that's me i'm sam morrison thank
you so much for having me and keep it
going for mitzi
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has the banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya